Back when the movie Schindler's List came out, I was friends with these two missionaries. They worked with Chicago gang kids who they would meet in prison and try to bring to God. Anyway-- one day I got a call from them. They just had seen Schindler's List, and they wanted to talk about it because, you know, call your Jewish friend. They'd seen Schindler's List, and I was their Jewish friend.
当电影《辛德勒的名单》上映时，我认识两位传教士朋友。他们经常去监狱里接触那些芝加哥街头的帮派少年，试图引导他们皈依上帝。有一天，我接到了他们的电话。他们刚看完《辛德勒的名单》，想跟我聊聊——毕竟，找个犹太朋友聊这个再合适不过了。他们看了电影，而我就是他们的那位犹太朋友。
Anyway, so we got together. And what they said was, first of all, "We think we understand you better now thanks to Schindler's List.." And I think what that was about was they knew about the Holocaust, of course, before this. But it was more of a kind of a historical fact like you read about in a book. The reality of what happened in the Holocaust I don't think ever had really hit them. The emotional reality of it just hadn't hit them in the gut-- all those people dying.
我们聚在一起谈论这部电影。他们首先说：“多亏了《辛德勒的名单》，我们现在觉得更理解你了。”我想他们的意思是，他们虽然早就知道大屠杀的历史，但那更像是在书本上读到的历史事实。在大屠杀中真实发生的一切，并没有真正触动他们。那种情感上的真实感——想到那么多人惨死——并没有真正击中他们的内心。
So we got together, and we talked about it. And they said the scene that touched them most was at the end of the film. And if you've seen Schindler's List, it's the scene after the war. And it's this rich guy, Schindler, who had been using his money during the war to save Jews from dying in concentration camps. And he realizes that now that the war is over, he could have saved so many more people. He still had money he hadn't used. He could have saved more people. And there's a scene where he goes from person to person saying stuff like, "I could have sold this pin and saved two more Jews. It's gold. Or this car."
我们聚在一起谈论这部电影。他们说电影最后的一幕最让他们动容。如果你看过《辛德勒的名单》，就会记得战后的那一幕。辛德勒是个富有的人，他在战争期间耗尽家财从集中营拯救犹太人。当战争结束时，他意识到自己本可以救下更多人。他还有没用完的钱，本可以救更多人的。电影里有一幕，他走到每个人面前说：“我本可以卖掉这枚胸针，多救两个犹太人。这是金子做的。还有这辆车。”
This car. What good would have bought this car? Why did I keep the car? 10 people right there.
这辆车。如果卖掉这辆车能换来什么？为什么我留着这辆车？卖掉它本可以救下10个人。
So we're talking about this scene, and my friends, Jane and Glen, the missionaries, say this thing that totally surprised me. They said, "That's us. That's our daily life, that scene. That's our life." This Saturday, for example, Glen says, he wanted to stay home and watch the ballgame on TV. But he thought to himself, "No, no. I've got to go out there, and I've got to save another kid. I've got to try to save another kid. I gotta go to the jail. I gotta go to juvie."
我们谈论着这一幕，我的朋友简和格伦，也就是那两位传教士，说出了一句让我完全震惊的话。他们说：“那就是我们。那一幕就是我们的日常生活。那就是我们的生活。”格伦说，就拿这个星期六来说，他本想待在家里看电视转播的球赛，但他心里想：“不，不行。我得走出去，去拯救另一个孩子。我必须试着去救另一个孩子。我得去监狱，得去少管所。”
And they both said that at the end of their lives, it's going to be just like that scene in Schindler's List. They're going to go to heaven, and they're going to be called into account. And it's going to be, "You took this day off, and you pretended to be doing paperwork. And you could have been out there saving another kid. Or you watched the doubleheader with Cincinnati, and there was a teenager who was ready to hear your message and come to God." And they were going to be held to account.
他们俩都说，在他们生命尽头时，也会像《辛德勒的名单》里的那一幕一样。他们将来到天堂，接受审判。到那时，人们会说：“你那天休息了，假装在忙文书工作。而你本可以走出去拯救另一个孩子。或者，你那天在看辛辛那提的双重赛，而当时有一个青少年正准备听你的教诲，准备皈依上帝。”他们将不得不为这些事承担责任。
I think before this conversation, my understanding of Jane and Glen's life was pretty much exactly like their understanding of the Holocaust. I understood in my head. I understood intellectually that they had given their lives over to serving God. I understood that as a fact. But what it actually meant had not totally penetrated me.
我想在这次谈话之前，我对简和格伦生活的理解，就像他们对大屠杀的理解一样。我在脑海中能理解。我在智力上明白他们已经献身于侍奉上帝。我明白这是一个事实。但它到底意味着什么，我还没有完全领悟。
Jane and Glen, my friends, they were like superheroes. They had this incredible power, the power to save somebody, to bring them to God, to turn somebody's life around. And I've got to say, I met kids whose lives were completely straightened out because of them. They did a really nice job. They did save kids. And with their great power came great responsibility, a responsibility they tried really, really hard to live up to.
简和格伦，我的朋友们，他们就像超级英雄。他们拥有令人难以置信的力量，那种拯救他人、引人向善、改变一个人命运的力量。我必须说，我见过一些孩子，他们的生活因为这对夫妇而完全步入了正轨。他们做得非常出色。他们确实拯救了孩子。而伟大的力量伴随着伟大的责任，他们确实非常、非常努力地去践行这份责任。
Well, today on our radio show, we have other people who feel that same sense of power and responsibility in their daily lives. And I'm not just talking here about judges and doctors and four-star generals and people you would expect and hope would feel the burden that comes with that amount of power. I'm talking about normal people, people you might not suspect.
今天在我们的电台节目中，我们将带大家认识其他人，他们在日常生活中也感受到了同样的力量感与责任感。我指的不仅仅是法官、医生、四星上将这些人们期望并希望能够承担权力重负的人。我说的是普通人，一些你可能根本想不到的人。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, "With Great Power," are shown in three acts. Act One, Objects in Side View Mirror Are Truer Than They Appear. Act Two, Unwelcome Wagon. Act Three, Waiting for Joe. In that act, Shalom Auslander has a tale of the being with more power than any other and more responsibility. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“伟大的力量”，共分三幕。第一幕：“后视镜中的物体比看起来更真实”。第二幕：“不受欢迎的推销”。第三幕：“等待乔”。在这一幕里，沙洛姆·奥斯兰德将讲述一个关于拥有比任何人都更大的权力和更多责任的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Objects in Side View Mirror Are Truer Than They Appear. Well, the woman in the heart of this next story has the power to change two people's lives. And the thing is, at the height of her power, she doesn't even know she has it. Alex Kotlowitz tells the story.
第一幕：“后视镜中的物体比看起来更真实”。接下来这个故事的核心人物，拥有改变两个人命运的力量。而关键在于，在她权力的巅峰时刻，她甚至不知道自己拥有这种力量。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨讲述了这个故事。
On this one August day in 1979, Carla Dimkoff learned something which shaped the rest of her life and the life of a complete stranger. And the thing about it is it took 26 years for her to realize that.
在1979年8月的一天，卡拉·迪姆科夫得知了一件事，这件事不仅改变了她自己的一生，也改变了一个陌生人的一生。但讽刺的是，她花了26年才意识到这一点。
At the time, Carla was 19 years old. She was living in a trailer home in the small town of White Cloud, Michigan, when her father, James Keller, who lived in Tennessee, showed up unannounced driving a motor home. Her father was a bit of a vagabond, someone who lived on the edge. So this surprise visit wasn't all that unusual.
当时，卡拉19岁。她住在密歇根州怀特克劳德镇的一辆活动房车里。她的父亲詹姆斯·凯勒住在田纳西州，那天他开着一辆露营车不请自来。她的父亲是个有点流浪癖的人，生活在社会边缘。所以这种突如其来的访问并不算太罕见。
He did this all the time. He would basically abandon my mom, and he would just take off for days at a time. And he would end up wherever he wanted in several different states. And this time, he ended back up in Michigan.
他经常这样做。他基本上抛弃了我母亲，动不动就离家好几天。他最后总会出现在几个不同州的他想去的任何地方。而这一次，他回到了密歇根。
Carla was kind of at loose ends herself. She'd been raising a daughter alone, and the day her father arrived, Carla had gotten married to a man she'd met just a week before. Her father gave them $20 as a wedding gift and wished them well. Then they went their separate ways for the evening. Carla and her new husband got home around 2:00 AM. But her father was still out. He stayed out most of the night.
卡拉自己也正处于一种茫然无措的状态。她独自抚养着一个女儿，而在她父亲到访的那天，卡拉刚和一个才认识一周的男人结婚。父亲给了他们20美元作为结婚礼物，祝他们幸福。然后那天晚上他们就各奔东西了。卡拉和新婚丈夫大约凌晨2点回到家，但她父亲还没回来。他几乎在外面待了一整晚。
When I got up the next morning-- it was fairly early. I want to say between 7:00 and 9:00, 10:00 AM. He was in the driveway. I walked outside, and I said, "Hi, where you been?" And at some point, he told me he'd been at the Lamp Lite Bar for a little while. And I was kind of puzzled because the bar is closed at 2:15 or 2:30. And I wondered where he had been the rest of the evening. And I really never got an answer to that.
第二天早上我起床的时候——时间还挺早，大概在早上7点到10点之间。他在车道上。我走出去问他：“嗨，你昨晚去哪了？”他在某个时刻告诉我，他去过Lamp Lite酒吧一会儿。我很困惑，因为酒吧2点15分或2点30分就关门了。我不知道他那天晚上剩下的时间都在哪里。我一直没得到答案。
Even stranger was what he was doing in the driveway. He was repairing the side view mirror on his motor home.
更奇怪的是他在车道上做的事。他正在修理他露营车的后视镜。
It had actually been broken off, and he was putting a whole new mirror on it. And he was just doing it in such a hurry and throwing parts into his vehicle, which I thought was strange. Why throw all the junk when you're 10 feet from a dumpster into the motor home? And he was in just such a hurry about it. It just struck me odd for a minute. And the next thing I know he said, "Well, I am out of here." And he left. And I didn't speak to him probably for several months to a year.
后视镜其实已经断了，他正在装一个全新的镜子。他做得非常匆忙，把零件扔进车里，我觉得这很奇怪。离垃圾桶只有10英尺远，为什么要直接把垃圾扔进车里？他显得那么着急。这一幕让我觉得很奇怪。接着我就听他说：“好了，我要走了。”然后他就离开了。在那之后，我有好几个月甚至一年没再跟他说过话。
It wasn't just that Carla's was father was a drifter. That makes him seem benign. He was, by Carla's recollection, a violent man. Carla remembers once she was slurping while eating spaghetti, and he hurled the table on its side.
卡拉的父亲不仅仅是个流浪汉，这听起来可能还算无害。据卡拉回忆，他是个暴力的人。卡拉记得有一次她吃意大利面时发出吸溜声，他就把桌子掀翻了。
But it was much worse than that. When Carla turned 11, her mother told her that her father had molested a young girl. Carla tried to protect others in the family, and that brought her into direct conflict with her dad. Like one of the times he went after her mother.
但情况比那糟糕得多。卡拉11岁时，母亲告诉她，父亲曾猥亵过一个年轻女孩。卡拉试图保护家里的其他人，这让她与父亲直接冲突。就像有一次，他对他母亲动手。
I stepped into the middle of it, and he punched me in the jaw. And I ended up in the emergency room later that evening.
我介入其中，结果他一拳打在我的下巴上。那天晚上我被送进了急诊室。
And how old were you?
当时你多大？
Around 16. At that point, I became afraid physically of my father and emotionally of him. And I was afraid to be alone with them after that.
大概16岁。从那时起，我开始在身体上和情感上都恐惧我的父亲。在那之后，我再也不敢和他单独相处。
This is all important to know in order to understand what happened next. Shortly after Carla's dad drove out of town, Carla picked up The Times Indicator, their local newspaper, and read that on the very same night her dad didn't come home, just hours before she found him in the driveway fixing his busted side view mirror, a 19-year-old woman had been killed on a nearby road, a deep gash in her head. In the article, the sheriff said, and I quote, "We assume she was hit by an unknown vehicle, maybe by a mirror or some projection."
了解这些对于理解接下来发生的事很重要。在卡拉的父亲离开小镇后不久，卡拉拿起当地报纸《泰晤士报指标》，读到在父亲彻夜未归的那个晚上，就在她看到父亲在车道上修理破碎后视镜的几小时前，一名19岁的年轻女子在附近的一条路上被杀害，头部有很深的伤口。报道中警长说，我引述他的话：“我们推测她是被一辆不知名的车撞了，可能是被后视镜或什么突出的部件撞击。”
I just thought, "Oh my God." I had an overwhelming feeling that my father had killed someone, and I just needed to tell what I knew.
我当时就想：“天哪。”我有一种强烈的感觉，是我父亲杀了人，我必须说出我知道的事。
At first, she went to her minister who urged her to go to the police, which she did the very next day. She had a friend drive her to the police station in town where she learned that the detective in charge of the case wasn't in. So she left him a note.
起初，她去找了牧师，牧师敦促她报警，她第二天就去了。她让一个朋友开车带她去镇上的警察局，结果得知负责案件的探员不在。于是她留下了一张字条。
This is the letter I wrote to Detective Foster. And it says, "Mr. Foster, I would like to speak with you concerning the death of Kristy Ringler. I do not have a car. If you could possibly stop out to my house after 3:00 PM today, it would be greatly appreciated. Thank you, Mrs. [? Terrel." ?]
这是我写给福斯特探员的信。上面写着：“福斯特先生，我想和您谈谈关于克里斯蒂·林格勒死亡的事。我没有车。如果您能方便在今天下午3点后到我家一趟，我将不胜感激。谢谢，特雷尔夫人。”
That evening, there were two detectives that actually came out. They were dressed in plain clothes. They knocked on the door. They came in. I told them the whole story about my dad had been here, he had been gone all night. Gave them just a little bit of a history of my dad-- not a whole lot of history. And they were like, "OK. Well, we have this information. Thank you."
那天晚上，确实有两名探员来了。他们穿着便衣。他们敲了门。进屋后，我告诉了他们关于我父亲来过、彻夜未归的整件事。给了他们一点我父亲的历史——不多。他们说：“好的。嗯，我们收到这些信息了。谢谢。”
I had the feeling when they came in the door that they thought they were wasting their time. I don't even think they sat down. They stood there just kind of towering over me. And I was clearly intimidated by the whole situation, not really ever dealing with anything like this. And maybe I just made myself sound unsure.
他们进门时我就有一种感觉，他们觉得在浪费时间。我觉得他们甚至没坐下。他们只是站在那里，居高临下地看着我。我当时被整个场面吓到了，毕竟从未处理过这种事。也许我表现得太不确定了。
You see, Carla laid out two possible scenarios for the detectives. One, that her father accidentally struck this girl while driving home from the Lamp Lite Bar. That seemed likely given his shattered side view mirror and his eagerness to get out of town. The other? Well, she thought it was possible that her father killed Kristy Ringler on purpose. That knowing her dad, maybe he tried to flirt with Kristy at the Lamp Lite, that maybe she'd repelled his advances, and that maybe on the way home he saw her on the road and rammed her with his side view mirror. Carla now believes, though, that this speculative scenario didn't sit too well with the detectives.
你看，卡拉为探员们提出了两种可能的情况。一种是，她父亲在从酒吧回家的路上意外撞到了这个女孩。鉴于他破碎的后视镜和急于离开小镇的表现，这似乎很有可能。另一种呢？她认为父亲可能是故意杀害了克里斯蒂·林格勒。了解她父亲，也许他试图在酒吧里调戏克里斯蒂，被她拒绝了，于是他在回家的路上看到她，就用后视镜撞了她。但卡拉现在认为，这个推测性的场景并没有被探员们采信。
They made me feel like a fool, like I had a grudge to grind when I was trying to get my father in trouble or something. And just this poor trailer park person.
他们让我觉得自己像个傻瓜，好像我只是为了报复父亲才来找麻烦。我就像个可怜的拖车公园里的边缘人。
And were you conscious about living in a trailer, about being poor?
你当时很在意自己住在拖车房、很贫穷这件事吗？
Very, very. I knew that wasn't the thing to do. I knew that's not where I wanted to be.
非常在意。我知道那不是该做的事。我知道那不是我想要的生活。
So the detectives leave, and you know in your heart of hearts that your dad was somehow involved in the death of this girl. What do you do with that knowledge?
所以探员们走了，而你心里清楚你父亲以某种方式参与了那个女孩的死。你如何处理这些知识？
I bury it.
我把它埋起来。
When she looks back on it, this was the moment of truth. This was her opportunity to act, and she feels like she just gave up without any kind of fight. Carla ordinarily didn't back down easily, but she'd been dismissed often before. In seventh grade, she went to a guidance counselor about her dad's alleged abuse, and all the counselor did was go tell her parents. Then remember the time she ended up in the emergency room? Well, she told a doctor there that are father had punched her. Nothing came of that either. So when the detectives disregarded what she had to say, it felt familiar, like this was how it was always going to be. Her dad would elude any responsibility for what he'd done. She wasn't about to confront her father, who she feared would physically hurt her if she did. And as for the authorities--
当她回首往事时，这是真相时刻。这是她采取行动的机会，但她觉得她没有做任何抗争就放弃了。卡拉平时并不是个容易退缩的人，但她之前总是被无视。七年级时，她因为父亲的虐待指控去找辅导员，结果辅导员只是转头告诉了她父母。还有记得她进急诊室那次吗？她告诉医生父亲打了她，但也什么都没发生。所以当探员们无视她的话时，这种感觉很熟悉，仿佛一切注定如此。她父亲会逃避他所做之事的责任。她不敢去当面对质父亲，因为她害怕他会伤害她。至于当局——
The thought never occurred to me to go back to the police. I didn't want to feel that feeling again of intimidation, of just being dismissed. And that's really a selfish thought now that I think about it.
我从来没想过要回去找警察。我不想再经历那种被恐吓、被无视的感觉。现在想想，这真是个自私的想法。
The thing was though, she couldn't keep it buried, at least emotionally. She thought about it all the time-- that her father in all likelihood, accidentally or purposefully, had killed someone and that she hadn't done enough about it.
但问题是，她无法让它埋没，至少在情感上无法做到。她一直想着这件事——她父亲很可能，无论是因为意外还是故意，杀了一个人，而她做得不够。
I had these horrible nightmares that this dead girl was walking down the street trying to chase after me. Her body's all dismembered. And I got the feeling in my dream-- God, I sound like a nut-- that she was chasing me. And I couldn't ever figure out, why are you chasing me? There's been times where I could not think about it or I would be a wreck.
我做了可怕的噩梦，梦见那个死去的女孩走在街上，试图追赶我。她的身体四分五裂。在梦里我有一种感觉——天哪，我听起来像个疯子——她在追我。我永远想不通，你为什么要追我？有时我无法不去想，否则我会崩溃的。
Can you remember a particular moment?
你能记得具体的时刻吗？
Yeah, I can remember one time driving in the car and just thinking about my life in general and all the things I had going on. And it always ends up with Kristy. And I often thought, "Oh, I could just stop thinking if I just hit that tree." Just tortured.
能。记得有一次开车时，我在想自己的人生和正在经历的事情。最后总是会想到克里斯蒂。我常常想：“哦，如果我撞上那棵树，也许我就不用再想了。”简直是折磨。
Taping this interview with Larry Pat Souter taking place in Newaygo County Sheriff's Department. Present at this interview is Larry Pat Souter, Deputy John Sutton, and Detective Charles Foster. Today's date is 8/27/79. The time is 15:00.
正在进行关于拉里·帕特·苏特对纽威戈县警长部门的审讯录音。在场有拉里·帕特·苏特、约翰·萨顿副警长和查尔斯·福斯特探员。日期是1979年8月27日。时间是15:00。
Carla wasn't the only person damaged by Kristy Ringler's death. There was the Ringler family, of course. But there was also someone else, this 27-year-old truck driver named Larry Souter. The tape you just heard is a taped police interview with Larry, a wiry built man with a charming smile who liked to party. And while he didn't live in White Cloud, the night of Ringler's death he had been visiting a friend there.
卡拉并不是唯一被克里斯蒂·林格勒之死摧毁的人。当然，还有林格勒一家。但还有另一个人，这个27岁的卡车司机名叫拉里·苏特。你刚才听到的录音是警方对拉里的采访，他是个体格精瘦、笑容迷人、喜欢参加派对的男人。虽然他不住在怀特克劳德，但林格勒遇害的那晚他正好去拜访那里的朋友。
I don't think we drank at his house, if I remember correctly. But we went down to what they call the Lamp Lite Bar, which would have been south of town. And we'd sat there and drank maybe three hours in the bar.
如果我没记错的话，我们没在他家喝酒。但我们去了镇南边的一家叫Lamp Lite的酒吧。我们在那里坐着喝了大约三个小时。
Larry met a woman at the Lamp Lite. It was Kristy Ringler. They caught each other's eye, and when Larry and his friend went to party down the road, there was Kristy as well.
拉里在酒吧遇见了一个女人。那就是克里斯蒂·林格勒。他们互相看中了对方，当拉里和朋友去路边的派对时，克里斯蒂也在场。
When you got to the house, what happened?
当你到家时发生了什么？
When we got the house I went in. Joe went in. And I think I sat around for about 15 minutes. [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我们到家后我进去了。乔也进去了。我想我坐了大约15分钟。
She was all of a sudden on the front steps, and I went out and sat on the front steps. When I went out into the front of yard there was a tree out there. Kinda sitting set up by the tree and stuff and kind of kissing a little bit and this and that. And then she got up. And she walked off and started walking towards town, which would be back north towards White Cloud.
她突然出现在前门台阶上，我走出去坐在台阶上。当我走到院子前面时，那里有一棵树。我们靠着树坐着，接吻什么的。然后她站起来。她走开了，开始向镇上走去，也就是回到北边的怀特克劳德。
Larry, who had a good deal to drink, says he offered to try to find her a ride. But she insisted she'd be all right. The last time Larry saw her, she was walking down the dark, two-lane road by herself. Two days after Ringler's death, the police asked Larry come down to the station for this questioning. The interview lasted an hour and 15 minutes. Larry didn't bring a lawyer. He didn't feel he had anything to hide.
拉里喝了不少酒，他说他主动提出想帮她找车送她。但她坚持说她自己没问题。拉里最后一次见到她，是她独自走在黑暗的双车道公路上。在林格勒死后的两天，警方要求拉里去警局接受问话。审讯持续了一个小时15分钟。拉里没有带律师。他觉得没什么可隐瞒的。
I've got nothing to hide.
我没什么好隐瞒的。
All right, this tape's going to be terminated at 16:15 on 8/27/79.
好了，这段录音在1979年8月27日16:15终止。
And I don't think I heard anything from them for probably 12 and 1/2 years.
在那之后，我想我有大概12年半没听到他们的消息。
Larry returned to his life, driving a truck and laying gas pipes. He got married to a woman named Melody, and they thought about starting a family together. Then one day--
拉里回到了他的生活中，开着卡车，铺设煤气管道。他和一位名叫梅洛迪的女人结婚了，他们考虑组建家庭。然后有一天——
One day I went to work-- which was November 14. And it's easy to remember because it was the day before deer season. And they came to work and they that you're under arrest for an open murder. I think that's what it was.
有一天我去上班——那是11月14日。很容易记住，因为那是鹿狩猎季节的前一天。他们来到单位说我因公开谋杀被捕了。我想大概是这样。
Did you know what they were talking about?
你知道他们在说什么吗？
I had no clue.
我毫无头绪。
This was in 1992-- like Larry said, 12 and 1/2 years after Kristy Ringler's death. A new sheriff had reopened the case, and it quickly got a lot of publicity. Larry, who's quiet and reserved, felt deeply embarrassed.
那是1992年——就像拉里说的，在克里斯蒂·林格勒死后12年半。一位新警长重启了案件，很快引起了广泛关注。性格安静、内敛的拉里感到非常尴尬。
My name was in the paper. My face was in the paper. It's like, "Oh, my God." I mean, this is humiliation.
我的名字登在了报纸上。我的脸登在了报纸上。感觉就像，“天哪。”这意味着羞辱。
Had you ever been arrested before?
你以前被捕过吗？
No, sir.
没有，先生。
But Larry assumed that justice would just find its way. This is Melody, his wife.
但拉里认为正义最终会降临。这是梅洛迪，他的妻子。
They offered him a plea bargain for two to five years if he would admit he did it. And he refused to because he didn't.
他们提供给他一项认罪协议，如果他承认做了，可以判二到五年。但他拒绝了，因为他根本没做。
And did he come to you for advice?
他来征求你的意见了吗？
We were there together.
我们当时都在一起。
What did you tell him?
你告诉他什么？
I told him, "You can't plead guilty to something you didn't do."
我告诉他：“你不能为你没做过的事情认罪。”
The prosecutors argued that Larry had bludgeoned Kristy Ringler with a pint-sized bottle of Canadian club whiskey. Their key piece of evidence was the testimony by pathologists that the bottom ridge of the bottle matched Ringler's injuries. At the trial, no mention was made of Carla's note and her subsequent interview with the detectives. The Souters believe the prosecution buried it. Larry was convicted and sentenced to 20 to 60 years.
检察官声称拉里用一品脱装的加拿大俱乐部威士忌瓶子殴打了克里斯蒂·林格勒。他们关键的证据是病理学家的证词，称瓶底的棱纹与林格勒的伤口吻合。在审判中，完全没有提及卡拉的字条和她随后的探员采访。苏特一家认为控方掩盖了这些。拉里被定罪，判处20到60年监禁。
My world just came right out from underneath me, in total shock. It was a nightmare, a straight up nightmare.
我的世界彻底崩塌了，完全处于震惊中。那是一场噩梦，彻头彻尾的噩梦。
There is, I suspect, nothing more confounding and debilitating than being sent to prison for something you didn't do. And the years behind bars had their effect on Larry as well as on his wife, Melody.
我想，没有什么比因为没做过的事被关进监狱更令人困惑和崩溃的了。这几年的牢狱生活对拉里和他的妻子梅洛迪都造成了深远影响。
Melody had a car accident after visiting Larry in prison and lost her factory job. She had to move back home with their parents where she spent most of her time going over and over trial transcripts and police reports. She gave up the idea of ever having children.
梅洛迪在去监狱探望拉里后发生了车祸，失去了工厂的工作。她不得不搬回父母家住，大部分时间都在反复研究审判记录和警方的报告。她放弃了生育孩子的念头。
I had a hysterectomy while he was in prison.
他在监狱里的时候我做了子宫切除术。
So you gave that up as well?
所以你也放弃了那个？
Yep.
是的。
And in the years Larry was in prison, he struggled to sustain himself, too. One of the ways he did that was to build these meticulously constructed Western scenes out of toothpicks-- log cabins, churches, saloons, covered bridges. He trimmed the toothpicks-- sometimes 2,500 of them for one model-- with a nail clipper so that they fit together with glue like cut logs. The hours upon hours spent constructing them helped keep his mind off his case.
在拉里坐牢的那些年里，他也努力支撑着自己。其中一种方法是用牙签精心建造西部场景模型——小木屋、教堂、沙龙、有顶桥。他用指甲刀修剪牙签——有时一个模型要用2500根——然后用胶水像搭积木一样粘在一起。花上数小时建造这些模型帮助他不去想自己的案子。
But over the years, Alex, I'll tell you what, yes, I was very, very bitter in there. But I'd just try to say to myself, just let it go. Take one day at a time.
但是这些年来，亚历克斯，我告诉你，是的，我在里面感到非常、非常痛苦。但我总是告诉自己，顺其自然吧。一天一天地过。
Larry and Melody believed there had to be someone out there with some knowledge about what happened that night. And so Melody, along with Larry's sister, searched and searched and searched.
拉里和梅洛迪相信一定有人知道那天晚上发生了什么。所以梅洛迪和拉里的妹妹一直在搜寻、搜寻、再搜寻。
We made trips to look for people. We went to Newaygo County when people told us we were crazy. We could get killed. And we interviewed people, we talked to people, we did everything we could to try to find out what really happened to this girl.
我们四处奔波寻找线索。我们去了纽威戈县，人们说我们疯了。我们可能会被杀。我们采访了人们，交谈，尽了一切努力去寻找那个女孩到底发生了什么。
Of course, the person they were looking for was Carla. But they didn't know she even existed. And Carla was completely unaware of them as well. In the 26 years since Kristy Ringerl's death, Carla had gotten divorced and remarried to a college professor. She now lived a comfortable life outside Grand Rapids in a spacious A-frame home on five acres of land. Her father had died in 1999, and all she could think about afterwards was he'd gotten away with it completely. And that tore at her.
当然，他们寻找的人正是卡拉。但他们甚至不知道她的存在。而卡拉也完全不知道他们。在克里斯蒂·林格勒去世后的26年里，卡拉离了婚，又嫁给了一位大学教授。她现在在大急流城外过着舒适的生活，住在一栋坐落于五英亩土地上的宽敞A型房子里。她父亲在1999年去世了，之后她想到的只有他完全逍遥法外了。这折磨着她。
And then one day in January of last year, she picked up a newspaper and read for the very first time about Larry Souter. Melody, Larry's wife, had convinced John Smietanka, former prosecutor, to take Larry's case. A medical examiner, who had testified at Larry's trial, now believed it was unlikely Ringler's wounds were caused by a whiskey bottle.
然后去年的一个一月，她拿起一份报纸，第一次读到了拉里·苏特的事。梅洛迪，拉里的妻子，说服了前检察官约翰·斯米坦卡接手拉里的案子。一位在拉里审判中作证的法医现在认为，林格勒的伤口不太可能是威士忌瓶子造成的。
I was sitting in here in this living room, and my husband was in the TV room. And I read this article about Kristy Ringler. And I'm like, "Oh, my God. Someone has been convicted of this." I'm telling you, I literally just about fell on the floor.
我当时坐在客厅里，丈夫在电视室。我读了那篇关于克里斯蒂·林格勒的文章。我想，“天哪。有人因此被定罪了。”我告诉你，我简直快要摔倒在地上。
At that moment, it hit Carla because she had held onto this knowledge about her father's probable involvement in Kristy Ringler's death, someone had been sent to prison. The very next morning she called Larry's lawyer and spoke with his associate.
那一刻，卡拉震惊了，因为她一直保守着关于她父亲可能参与克里斯蒂·林格勒之死的秘密，却有人被关进了监狱。第二天一早，她就给拉里的律师打了电话，并与他的合伙人谈了话。
I said to her, "You might think I'm a crazy woman or something because I'm sure you don't get these phone calls all the time. But I know this Larry Souter story that you're working on, and I reported that my dad killed that girl."
我对她说：“你可能觉得我疯了，因为我肯定你不会经常接到这样的电话。但我知道你正在处理的这个拉里·苏特的故事，我曾举报说我父亲杀了那个女孩。”
They did, in fact, worry she might be a crazy person. No one had ever seen anything from the police indicating that they'd interviewed Carla. So the attorneys quickly filed a Freedom of Information Act request, and in a stack of police reports they received, they found the very note that Carla had left for Detective Foster as well as half a page of nearly indecipherable notes the detectives took from an apparent phone interview with her father.
他们确实担心她可能是个疯子。因为从来没有任何警方记录表明他们曾采访过卡拉。所以律师们迅速提交了《信息自由法》请求，在收到的一堆警方报告中，他们发现了卡拉留给福斯特探员的那张字条，以及探员从显然是与她父亲的电话采访中记下的半页几乎难以辨认的笔记。
One thing led to another, and within two months, Larry Souter got word that the authorities finally believed him. His conviction was vacated. And after 13 years and 18 days in prison, on April 1 of last year he walked out a free man. Carla at first asked the attorneys to keep her identity hidden, though that was impossible because it was such a public case. Mostly, she felt she completely failed this man, this stranger, Larry Souter.
事情一步接一步，不到两个月，拉里·苏特就得到了当局终于相信他的消息。他的定罪被撤销了。在监狱里待了13年18天后，去年的4月1日，他走出来成为一个自由人。卡拉起初要求律师隐瞒她的身份，但这不可能，因为这是一起如此公开的案件。大部分时间里，她感到自己彻底辜负了这个男人，这个陌生人，拉里·苏特。
I cried for a long time-- weeks.
我哭了很长时间——几个星期。
About two months after being released from prison, Larry told his lawyer that he wanted to meet Carla. So they agree to have lunch at a local Applebee's, and Carla prepared herself for Larry's fury.
出狱后大约两个月，拉里告诉律师他想见卡拉。于是他们同意在当地的一家Applebee餐厅共进午餐，卡拉做好了迎接拉里愤怒的准备。
My husband literally had to help me out of car I was trembling so much. And I knew who he was right away when he walked in. And we just both kind of collapsed in tears. I wasn't sure why he was crying, but I was just so overwhelmed with guilt that I could hardly look at him.
我丈夫简直是把我从车里搀出来的，我当时颤抖得太厉害了。他一走进来，我就认出了他。我们两个都崩溃大哭了。我不知道他为什么要哭，但我沉浸在强烈的负罪感中，几乎不敢看他。
On a recent afternoon, Larry came by to see Carla. Somewhat surprisingly, they've become friends. And in an odd twist of fate, they're both battling cancer and have helped each other out during their respective treatments. On this rainy afternoon, the two stood in the kitchen in a tight embrace. And as they held each other, Carla became overwhelmed with guilt and began to cry.
最近的一个下午，拉里过来找卡拉。令人惊讶的是，他们成了朋友。命运开了一个奇怪的玩笑，他们都在与癌症作斗争，并在各自的治疗过程中互相帮助。在这个多雨的午后，两人在厨房紧紧拥抱。当他们相拥时，卡拉再次被负罪感淹没，哭了起来。
It's gonna be all right.
一切都会好起来的。
I'm sorry. Sorry. I'm so sorry.
对不起。抱歉。我真的很抱歉。
Carla can't help herself. Whenever she sees Larry, she breaks down and apologizes. There was even a period of two months when Carla wouldn't return Larry's phone calls.
卡拉无法自已。每当见到拉里，她就会崩溃并道歉。甚至有一次，卡拉有两个月没接拉里的电话。
Because you can only apologize so many times, and I felt the need to do it all the time.
因为你不能一直道歉，而我当时觉得必须一直这么做。
It just seems like you're awfully hard on yourself. You've righted something, you gave somebody his freedom.
你对自己好像太苛刻了。你修正了一件错事，你给了某人自由。
I didn't give Larry his freedom. What he didn't do gave him his freedom. If I was going to give him his freedom, I would have given it to him 13 years ago. And I didn't do that, and that's where I failed.
我没有给拉里自由。是他没做过的事给了他自由。如果说是我给了他自由，我本应在13年前就给他。但我没做到，那就是我失败的地方。
But I think you're being so hard on yourself. You didn't know he was there.
但我认为你对自己要求太苛刻了。你当时不知道他在哪里。
No, but I knew what the right thing at the moment was. In my heart of hearts I knew what was happening, and I just let it go. And I don't understand a person that can do that.
不，但我当时心里知道该做什么。我心底深处知道发生了什么，但我还是放过了它。我不理解一个人怎么能那样做。
Here's the strange thing about all this. In certain ways, all of this has been harder for Carla to handle than for Larry. Sometimes you happen upon a moment. You'll witness something on the street. Let's say a man's threatening a woman or a parent's hitting a child, and the fate of a complete stranger rests on how you handle things. And you feel powerless to do anything. So you turn your head. You walk away. Or as in Carla's case, you try to do something but not forcefully enough. And then you resume your life though those moments stay with you.
这里有关于这一切奇怪的事情。在某些方面，处理这一切对卡拉来说比对拉里更难。有时你正好碰上一刻。你目睹街上发生的事，比如一个男人威胁一个女人，或者一个家长打孩子，而一个陌生人的命运取决于你怎么处理。你感到无力改变什么。于是你转过头。你走开了。或者像卡拉一样，你试图做点什么，但不够坚定。然后你继续过你的生活，尽管那些瞬间一直伴随着你。
Well, imagine if you got a second chance. Carla did, and she paid a price for getting a second shot at it. Now she's even more tormented because it really has sunk in, the kind of power she held 26 years earlier. And so she feels ashamed. Larry, though, sees it all quite differently.
嗯，想象一下你得到了第二次机会。卡拉得到了，她为得到这次机会付出了代价。现在她更加痛苦了，因为那种26年前她掌握的权力性质已经深深触动了她。所以她感到羞愧。然而，拉里却以完全不同的方式看待这一切。
She's my angel.
她是我的天使。
That's what he calls me, his angel. Matter of fact, he brought me a gift a couple weeks ago. It's a lawn ornament, and it has--
这就是他叫我的名字，他的天使。事实上，几个星期前他给我带了一件礼物。那是一个草坪装饰品，上面有——
Couple angels on it.
上面有几个天使。
Couple angels on it. And it lights up at night. I want you to know I go out in the middle of the night when I can't sleep, and I look at it.
上面有几个天使。晚上还会发光。我想让你知道，我睡不着觉的时候会在半夜走出去，看着它。
While Carla spends sleepless nights staring at her angels, remembering the past, Larry's trying to forget. Right after he got released, he and Melody built a bonfire to burn all the clothes and letters associated with his time in prison.
当卡拉在失眠之夜凝视着她的天使、回忆过去时，拉里却试图忘记。刚获释后，他和梅洛迪燃起篝火，烧掉了所有与他在监狱里生活相关的衣服和信件。
Not long ago as a gift, Larry gave one of his toothpick constructions to Carla. She has it displayed in her living room. It's a log cabin with a chimney, built with pebbles Larry collected from the prison yard. This, of course, is what Larry did to forget. But now Carla has it as a constant reminder.
不久前，拉里送了一个他的牙签建筑作为礼物给卡拉。她把它展示在客厅里。那是一个带烟囱的小木屋，是用拉里从监狱操场收集的鹅卵石建造的。这当然是拉里为了忘记而做的。但现在它成了卡拉的一个持续不断的提醒。
Alex Kotlowitz is the author of several books, most recently, Never a City So Real. We first broadcast this story two years ago.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨是多本书的作者，最近的作品是《从不如此真实的城市》。我们两年前首次播出了这个故事。
Coming up, a family wishes for years for the power to defend themselves against a dangerous neighbor. And then they get it. And they have to decide if they want to use that power. Back in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个家庭多年来一直渴望获得保护自己免受危险邻居伤害的力量。然后他们得到了。他们必须决定是否要使用那种力量。几分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，我们将从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际回来。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're new to this program, of course, we choose a theme, ranging from a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "With Great Power," stories about ordinary people who find themselves with these superheroes' dilemmas. With great power comes great responsibility. We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你是第一次收听这个节目，我们通常会选择一个主题，并围绕这个主题展开各种不同的故事。今天的节目，“伟大的力量”，讲述的是一些发现自己陷入超级英雄困境的普通人的故事。能力越大，责任越大。我们已经来到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Unwelcome Wagon. There's a kind of a power that only means something if you don't use it. Like for example, threatening to use a nuclear weapon. This story's about something like that. Except instead of taking place in the desolate borders of rival nations who hate to fear each other, it occurs entirely in a quiet street in the suburbs between next-door neighbors. We've changed the names of everybody you're going to hear from in the story. As we go along you'll see why.
第二幕：“不受欢迎的推销”。有一种力量，只有在你不用它的时候才有意义。比如，威胁使用核武器。这个故事就是关于类似的事情。只不过它不是发生在相互敌视的竞争国家荒凉的边界上，而是完全发生在一个安静的郊区街道，发生在邻居之间。我们改变了故事中所有人物的名字。随着故事的展开，你会明白原因。
It begins years ago with a woman, who we're going to call Betty, and her husband when they decided to move from the inner city to a quiet, suburban neighborhood. Their kids were young. At first it was great. But then their next-door neighbor decided he was going to build a fence on what he thought was the property line.
一切始于多年前，一个我们称之为贝蒂的女人和她的丈夫，当他们决定从内城搬到一个安静的郊区社区时。那时他们的孩子还小。起初一切都很棒。但后来他们的隔壁邻居决定在他认为的财产边界上建一道围栏。
And he kept saying, "I know where the property line is. I've lived here 12 years, and I'm putting my fence on it." And my husband said, "Well, we should get a survey because our deed doesn't show it there."
他一直在说：“我知道地界在哪里。我住在这里12年了，我要把栅栏建在那儿。”我丈夫说：“嗯，我们应该做个测量，因为我们的地契没有显示在那儿。”
So we asked him to do a survey, and he refused.
所以我们请他进行测量，他拒绝了。
Here's Betty's daughter, who's now all grown up, who we'll call Julia.
这是贝蒂的女儿，现在已经长大了，我们称她为朱莉娅。
So we had a survey done anyway.
所以我们还是做了测量。
Of all things, the survey gave even more land to the neighbor than he thought he had, which you would think would have made him happy. But in fact, Betty and Julia say, it just made him mad because he had not waited for the survey to start building this fence. And now, thanks to the survey that he had not wanted, his yard was actually bigger. And he had to move the fence.
出人意料的是，测量结果显示邻居拥有的土地比他自己认为的还要多，你可能以为这会让他高兴。但事实上，贝蒂和朱莉娅说，这只会让他更生气，因为他没等测量就开始建那道栅栏了。现在，多亏了他根本不想要的测量，他的院子实际上更大了。他必须搬动栅栏。
He was very angry. And he was going to sue us because he said we made him put his fence in the wrong place. It all started from that.
他非常生气。他还要起诉我们，因为他说我们让他把栅栏放错了地方。这一切都由此开始。
And so how much of this fight was actually about the property and how much was it that he just didn't like the look of you?
那么，这场争吵有多少是关于财产的，又有多少是因为他就是不喜欢你们？
I'm guessing about 10% about the property, 90% didn't like us. The word that they used often about us-- and he very often-- was, "You people ain't from here." We were just different, I guess, than--
我猜10%是关于财产，90%是不喜欢我们。他经常用来形容我们的话是，“你们这些外来人，不是这儿的人。”我想我们就是和……有点不同。
We were liberals.
我们是自由派。
Yes.
是的。
We were liberals.
我们是自由派。
We looked different. We acted different.
我们看起来不同。我们的行为也不同。
After that, things started happening. And they started small. One day Betty was on the phone, and she looked out the window towards the neighbor's yard. Each of the two houses had a long driveway coming back from the road, and the two driveways were nearly side by side. The neighbor's truck was in his driveway near the two houses.
在那之后，事情开始发生了。都是些小事。有一天，贝蒂在打电话，她看向窗外邻居的院子。两栋房子都有通往马路的长车道，两道车道几乎挨在一起。邻居的卡车就在靠近两栋房子的车道上。
I could see cigarettes being relit out in his vehicle, and I realized that he sat in his vehicle and watched us.
我能看到他在车里重新点烟，我意识到他总是坐在车里盯着我们看。
So he watched us for hours into our living room, which had these big picture windows.
所以他对着我们的起居室看了几个小时，那里有大的落地窗。
And I can't think of anything more boring than watching us, but he did.
我实在想不出比盯着我们看更无聊的事了，但他就是做了。
Especially after we got cable.
特别是我们装了有线电视之后。
That was the beginning.
那是开始。
Wait, so he would just sit there for hours. You guys are like, coming in and out of the family room with a bowl of popcorn. You sit in front of the TV, and you're like, that's what he--
等等，所以他就是那样坐几个小时？你们就像，带着一碗爆米花进进出出家庭室。你们坐在电视机前，你们就那样——
Exactly.
完全正确。
Wow.
哇。
And we didn't go to anybody, because he can sit out in his truck if he wants to. It's a little strange.
我们没去找任何人，因为如果他想待在车里那是他的自由。虽然这有点奇怪。
At first they figured he would just lose interest and stop. But he didn't stop. Other things started happening. They got crank calls. For a while, every time they sat down to dinner they got a call. Their license plate disappeared. The lights outside their house were shot out with a BB gun. They called the cops, only to be told that if they wanted to go to case, they needed to capture the crimes on videotape, which they tried to do. And more interesting than anything else, every time they left the house it seemed like the neighbor was waiting for them.
起初他们以为他会失去兴趣并停下来。但他没停。其他事情开始发生了。他们接到了恶作剧电话。有一阵子，他们每次吃晚饭都会接到电话。他们的车牌不见了。他们房子外面的灯被气枪打坏了。他们报了警，结果被告知如果想立案，需要用录像带拍下犯罪过程，他们尝试了。更有趣的是，每次他们离开房子，邻居似乎都在等着他们。
We could not go outside without some interaction, without him yelling or insulting us in some way.
我们无法走到外面，而不发生某种互动，不被他以某种方式吼叫或侮辱。
And what would he yell?
他会吼什么？
Oh, well, to me, it was always the same.
噢，对我来说，总是那几句。
OK, wait just a minute. Stop the tape right there. A real quick warning to listeners, a nice Southern lady is about to get a little salty.
好的，等一下。暂停录音。给听众一个快速警告，一位可爱的南方女士马上要开始骂人了。
Oh, well, to me it was always the same. "Get your ugly old ass out here. You ugly old bitch. You old bitch shouldn't be on this earth." To my husband it would be, "You ain't no man. There's nothing to you. You're worthless. You let your wife wear the pants in the family."
噢，对我来说，总是那几句。“滚出来，你那丑陋的老东西。你这丑陋的老巫婆。你这老巫婆根本不该活在这个世上。”对我丈夫，他会说：“你根本不是个男人。你毫无价值。你让你妻子管家里的事。”
And he sat there with popcorn, watching us and mocking us and saying, "All y'all are putting on a big show. Y'all want some popcorn?" And offered it to my dad.
他坐在那里吃着爆米花，看着我们，嘲弄我们，说：“你们都在演大戏呢。要来点爆米花吗？”还向我爸爸推销。
Wait, and what were you all doing?
等等，你们当时在干什么？
Just going into the garage, maybe to get a bike or to get some old furniture out from storage.
只是进车库，也许是去拿辆自行车，或者从仓库取点旧家具。
It's such a commitment to messing with you.
他真是铁了心要折腾你们。
Yes, it was his life.
是的，那就是他的生活。
One morning they woke up to find this neighborly greeting-- the words bitch and whore literally carved into the lawn in giant block letters. One set was up by the house, the other set, down by the curb.
一天早上他们醒来，发现这种邻里的“问候”——“巫婆”（bitch）和“妓女”（whore）这两个词用巨大的块状字体刻在草坪上。一组在房子旁边，另一组在路边。
And they were done with some type of very strong weed killer.
它们是用某种非常强力的除草剂做出来的。
That would last year.
那得维持一年。
Yeah, we would either have to have them dug out and dig down like two feet or they were going to be there for a year. They were there for a year.
是的，要么我们得把它们挖出来挖深两英尺，要么它们就得在那里待一年。它们确实待了一年。
And so people would drive by your house for a year, and the word whore would be down on the lawn?
所以人们开车经过你们家一年，而“妓女”这个词就在草坪上？
The bus would pick me up for school in eighth grade, and it would be there. No one would say anything, though.
八年级时校车来接我上学，那个词就在那儿。不过没人说什么。
There was also a picture we interpreted to be a dog doing an obscene act with a woman.
还有一张图片，我们理解为一只狗对一个女人做猥亵动作。
You mean he drew it on the lawn?
你的意思是他在草坪上画的？
With the weed killer, yes.
用除草剂，是的。
A dog and a woman?
一只狗和一个女人？
Uh-huh. It was good enough that neighbors knew what it was.
嗯哼。画得够清楚，邻居们都知道那是什么。
And did you have the feeling that the entire neighborhood was against you?
你觉得整个社区都反对你们吗？
Yes.
是的。
Really, like everybody sided with him?
真的，好像每个人都站在他那边？
I don't know that I would go so far to say they sided with him, but more the feeling that "You've stirred up something in the neighborhood that we didn't want stirred up."
我不知道能不能说他们站在他那边，但更像是一种感觉，“你们在这个社区搅起了我们不想搅起的动静。”
That we set him off somehow, and that it was our fault.
是我们以某种方式招惹了他，这是我们的错。
They have other stories. The neighbor would play chicken with their car. He'd point his headlights into their house for hours, flash them on and off. When they went away on vacation, he would drive onto their lawn, spin the tires. When Julia's little brother went out on his bike, the neighbor would get on a bike himself sometimes and circle the little brother, lunge at him so he'd fall off. He was only eight. It was strange, they say, to feel that somebody hated them so much.
他们还有其他故事。邻居会开车跟他们玩“胆小鬼游戏”。他会把车头灯对着他们家几个小时，闪来闪去。当他们去度假时，他会把车开进他们的草坪，猛踩油门。当朱莉娅的弟弟骑车出门时，邻居有时也会骑上自行车，绕着弟弟转，猛地冲向他，让他摔倒。他才八岁。他们说，感觉到有人如此仇恨他们，这种感觉很奇怪。
At some point, he started going after your pets?
在某种程度上，他开始针对你们的宠物？
Yeah.
是的。
This was a very emotional thing for me. We didn't tell Julia about it until this past year.
这对我是非常情感化的事。直到去年我们才告诉朱莉娅这件事。
Not all the details. I was an animal lover as a kid.
不是全部细节。我小时候是个动物爱好者。
She was.
她是。
I always took home the cat on the side of the road. And I had a little black cat named Phoenix, and he killed it.
我总是把路边的猫捡回家。我有一只叫凤凰的小黑猫，他把它杀死了。
He killed it?
他杀了它？
One day we found Phoenix beside the fence, but just pushed through the bottom of the fence on our property. And if you looked across his driveway at the end of this house, there was a big metal baseball bat leaning against the house. Well, by that time we had attorneys. And they said, "Take the cat and have it autopsied." And we did, and it had been killed by two blows to it. But that was a part of him. He not only killed the cat, but he wanted you to know how he did it. And by leaving the bat, we knew what happened.
有一天我们发现凤凰躺在篱笆旁边，被从我们财产的栅栏底部塞了进来。如果你看向他车道那一头的房子，墙边靠着一根金属棒球棍。嗯，到那时我们已经有了律师。他们说，“把猫拿去做尸检。”我们做了，它是被两记重击杀死的。但那就是他的一部分。他不仅杀了猫，还想让你知道他是怎么做的。通过留下棍子，我们知道了发生了什么。
He had left it out by the driveway for me to find while I waited for the school bus, but it was a snow day that day. So my parents were the ones who found it.
他把它留在了车道旁边让我等校车时发现，但那天下雪了。所以是我父母发现的。
And so did you not find out about it for years later?
所以你们很多年后才知道这件事？
I just knew he died.
我只知道它死了。
We just couldn't tell her.
我们实在没法告诉她。
They thought about moving. They even put their house on the market after the words bitch and whore had grown back in the lawn, of course. But the economy wasn't so great. The house didn't sell. So they stayed, vowing not to let the neighbor get to them. This wasn't easy. By now they were in the middle of basically an all-out war. There were restraining orders and counter-restraining orders and court charges and counter charges. By this time, both sides are videotaping each other, Betty and her husband trying over and over to get some proof that would finally incriminate the neighbor and stop him and never getting it. So that's how it went for over two years.
他们想过搬家。在草坪上的“巫婆”和“妓女”词汇再次长出来后，他们当然把房子挂牌出售了。但经济状况不太好。房子没卖出去。所以他们留了下来，发誓不让邻居得逞。这不容易。到目前为止，他们基本上处于一场全面战争中。有限制令、反限制令、法庭指控和反指控。此时，双方都在给对方录像，贝蒂和她丈夫一次又一次地试图获得能最终指控邻居并阻止他的证据，却从未得到。事情就这样持续了两年多。
And then, a fateful pile of garbage dumped onto their lawn, a pile of garbage that was actually able to change the balance of power, giving Julia and Betty and their family both great power and great responsibility. The neighbor had thrown trash on their property before. Mostly little things-- cans, cigarette butts-- nothing interesting, nothing useful.
然后，一堆倒在他们草坪上的垃圾，一堆实际上能够改变权力平衡的垃圾，给了朱莉娅、贝蒂和她们的家庭既伟大的力量，又沉重的责任。邻居以前就在他们的财产上倒过垃圾。主要是些小东西——罐头、烟头——没什么意思，没什么用处。
But one day we went out, and there was a whole lot of stuff. It was papers, letters, bank statements, a mortgage. They had everything about them. That series of numbers that makes us the person we are in America.
但有一天我们走出去，发现了一大堆东西。是文件、信件、银行对账单、抵押贷款。他们拥有关于他们的一切。那串让我们在美国成为个人的数字。
You mean the social security number?
你是说社会安全号码？
His social security number, yes. He and his wife's. I always suspected it was maybe the wife got mad at him or one of the daughters, because they were adult, young women. And actually in that pile of stuff were letters from the daughters saying, "Oh, Mom, Daddy's terrible and you're good." And personal things as well as business-type things.
他的社会安全号码，是的。他和妻子的。我一直怀疑可能是妻子生他的气，或者是他的女儿们中的一个，因为她们都是成年的年轻女性。在那堆东西里实际上还有来自女儿们的信，写着：“哦，妈妈，爸爸太可怕了，你人真好。”以及私人的和商业相关的东西。
You photocopied a few of these and sent them to us. That's them, I have them here. They are so unbelievably personal you feel embarrassed to read them.
你复印了一些寄给了我们。就是这些，我在这儿。它们非常私人，读起来让你感到尴尬。
You do, you do.
确实，确实。
One of them starts with a sort of caveat, "I hope you never read this letter because if you do, it means that things are just very bad between us." And another one, one of the daughters sort of says, "Well, I'm writing this letter while you and Dad are fighting over some silly stuff." And it's so heartbreaking.
其中一封以一种警告开头：“我希望你永远读不到这封信，因为如果你读到了，意味着我们之间的情况已经非常糟糕了。”另一封信，其中一个女儿说：“嗯，我写这封信的时候，你和爸爸正在为一些愚蠢的事情争吵。”这太令人心碎了。
It is. He was so mean, and that showed what his family thought of him, how he had raised them to be, what his wife thought of him. We were a family that loved each other. We had dinner together, and we still laughed and had fun.
确实。他那么刻薄，这显示了他的家人是怎么看他的，他如何教育她们，以及他的妻子是怎么看他的。我们是一个互爱的家庭。我们一起吃饭，我们依然欢笑、快乐。
So suddenly, you guys had his social security number and all these bank numbers and all that. And you saved it?
所以突然间，你们掌握了他的社会安全号码和所有这些银行号码等等。你们保留了它？
Yes, we have.
是的，我们保留了。
We have a briefcase, and it's our little treasure chest.
我们有一个公文包，那是我们的小宝藏盒。
So really, suddenly you had a tremendous leverage over him. You can really do some damage.
所以真的，突然间你对他有了巨大的杠杆。你真的可以造成一些损害。
Right.
对。
Did you think about it?
你们想过吗？
Oh, yes. We talked about it.
噢，想过。我们谈论过。
What did you think about doing?
你们想过做什么？
Oh, closing up his business and bank account.
噢，关闭他的生意和银行账户。
And posting all his information in some truck stop or in many truck stops across the Southeast so that somebody could steal it.
还有把他的所有信息发布在某个卡车休息站，或者是整个东南部的一堆卡车休息站，这样别人就可以窃取它。
Just like posting his social security number.
就像发布他的社会安全号码。
Right.
对。
Yeah, making him a child porn person so he could never live anywhere comfortable again.
是的，让他成为儿童色情犯罪者，这样他就再也无法在任何地方过上安稳日子了。
Put him on a sex offender list and attribute it to Hezbollah. He could join NAMBLA.
把他列入性犯罪者名单，并归咎于真主党。他可以加入北美男童爱恋协会（NAMBLA）。
Any of those type things would be good.
任何这些事情都是好的。
There's the joy in your voice as your saying these things.
你们说这些话时，声音里有一种喜悦。
Yeah.
是的。
So now they had a great power to mess with their neighbor, to punish their neighbor-- he would never know what hit him. He would have no idea it was them. And despite what were I have to say clearly hours and hours that they spent talking about their revenge fantasies, they held their fire. They showed restraint.
所以现在他们有一种伟大的力量去折腾邻居，惩罚邻居——他永远不会知道是什么击中了他。他根本不知道是他们干的。尽管我必须说，他们确实花了几个小时几个小时谈论这些复仇幻想，但他们还是收手了。他们展现了克制。
We had the thoughts, but we never did anything.
我们有这些想法，但从未做过任何事。
So it was just nice to hold onto them in the special briefcase as a sort of secret weapon.
所以保留在那个特殊公文包里作为某种秘密武器，感觉挺好的。
Yes, like we have a little piece of him in this briefcase.
是的，就像我们在这个公文包里掌握了他的一小部分。
And at any time we could do something with it.
而且在任何时候，我们都可以用它做点什么。
Well, in a way then the main thing that finding all these papers that it gives you, it's like a gift because it helps with the one thing you've got which is being able to fantasize about revenge.
那么某种程度上，发现所有这些文件给你们的，就像是一份礼物，因为它有助于你们所拥有的一件事，那就是能够幻想复仇。
Right.
对。
That's true. And if we ever used it, that would be gone. If we put it out in the truck stop or did something on the internet, that would be gone. We would have done our thing. And we still can fantasize.
是真的。如果我们真的使用了它，那些东西就没了。如果我们把它放在卡车休息站或者在网上做点什么，那它就没了。我们就真的动手了。但现在我们依然可以幻想。
But it would be different if we didn't have these things because saying if you have no power then not using power means nothing. But we have the power to do something, but we choose not to. It gives us control over him and control over him in a way we never had when he was tormenting us.
但如果我们没有这些东西情况就不同了，因为如果你没有权力，那么不使用权力什么也不是。但我们拥有做某事的力量，却选择不做。这给了我们对他的控制，一种他在折磨我们时我们从未拥有过的控制感。
Eventually the neighbor moved away, stopping back to harass them only occasionally. Julia and Betty and their family moved later. But after all these years, they've kept that briefcase full of papers. You never know when it is that you're going to need your secret super power.
最终邻居搬走了，偶尔才回来骚扰他们一次。朱莉娅、贝蒂和她们的家人后来搬家了。但这么多年过去了，她们一直保留着那个塞满文件的公文包。你永远不知道什么时候会用到你的秘密超能力。
[MUSIC - "I GOT TO GET AWAY" BY DAVE BARKER]
[音乐 - 戴夫·巴克演唱《我必须离开》]
Act Three, Waiting for Joe. Well, in this act we make little shift. Now, this is going to be a story about somebody with great power, but the story is going to be told from the point of view of the powerless. When you're powerless, you spend a lot of time speculating about those above you, much more than the other way around, I think. The people above us, they do not care. They don't notice you and me, not in the same way.
第三幕：“等待乔”。嗯，在这一幕里，我们做了一点小转变。现在，这将是一个关于拥有巨大权力的人的故事，但故事将从无权无势者的角度来讲述。当你无权无势时，你会花很多时间揣测你上面的人，我想比反过来要多得多。那些处于我们上面的人，他们不在乎。他们没有注意到你和我，不是以同样的方式。
But we think a lot about them-- our parents, our bosses, our bosses' bosses. "What is going through their heads?" we think. "Why are they treating us this way, especially when they don't seem to be living up to their responsibilities?" And there is one figure like this more than any other. Shalom Auslander has the story.
但我们思考他们很多——我们的父母、我们的老板、我们老板的老板。“他们的脑子里在想什么？”我们想。“为什么他们这样对待我们，特别当他们看起来没有履行责任时？”有一个人物比任何人都更像这样。沙洛姆·奥斯兰德带来了这个故事。
In the beginning, he was always on time. But it had been a long time since the beginning, longer than either Doughnut or Danish could remember. "I don't get it," complained Danish. "Isn't it time?" "It's time," answered Doughnut. "It feels like it's time. It's time."
起初，他总是准时。但距离开始已经过了很长时间，比“甜甜圈”和“丹麦酥”记忆中的都要长。“我不明白，”丹麦酥抱怨道。“时间到了吗？”“是时候了，”甜甜圈回答。“感觉是时候了。是时候了。”
Danish paced anxiously back and forth. Of course it was time. He knew it was time. He didn't need Doughnut to tell him that it was time. "So where is he, then?" asked Danish.
丹麦酥焦急地走来走去。当然是时候了。他知道是时候了。他不需要甜甜圈来告诉他。“那他在哪儿呢？”丹麦酥问。
Doughnut sat curled up inside their cold, empty feeding bowl, focused intently on the doorknob of the apartment front door, believing with all of his heart that at any moment the doorknob would turn, the door would open, and Joe would appear.
甜甜圈蜷缩在他们寒冷、空空的食盆里，专注地盯着公寓前门的门把手，打心底里相信在某一刻门把手会转动，门会打开，乔会出现。
"We cannot pretend to think that we know what Joe knows and what Joe doesn't know," pronounced Doughnut with a sharp twitch of his nose, "we must only believe with all of our heart that Joe knows."
“我们不能自以为知道乔知道什么，不知道什么，”甜甜圈抽动着鼻子郑重地说，“我们必须打心底里相信乔知道。”
"I bet he doesn't know!" said Danish. He rose up on his hind legs and flailed uselessly at the glass walls until he became exhausted. Breathing heavily, he lumbered over to the water bottle that hung in the far corner and drew a few drops into his mouth.
“我敢说他不知道！”丹麦酥说。他站起来用后腿站立，徒劳地拍打着玻璃墙，直到精疲力竭。呼吸急促，他蹒跚着走向挂在远角的饮水瓶，喝了几滴水。
"You nonbelievers are all the same," scoffed Doughnut. He pushed some dry cedar chips into a small, comfortable mound and settled down upon it. "As if you were the first hamster to ever doubt him!" he said. "Joe knows who believes, Danish, and Joe knows who doesn't. Joe is here, Joe is there, Joe is simply everywhere. You look around at all your plastic tube highways, and your fabulous Habitrail and think you are special. But do ants not build anthills? Do bees not build hives? It is not what we build that makes us unique, it is what we believe; it is that we believe at all! Doubt, my dear Danish, is no great achievement; it is faith that sets us apart. Besides," added Doughnut, "he left his wallet on the front table. He's got to come back."
“你们这些不信的人都一样，”甜甜圈嘲笑道。他把一些干燥的雪松木屑推成一个小而舒适的土堆，在上面安顿下来。“好像你是第一个怀疑他的仓鼠似的！”他说。“乔知道谁相信，丹麦酥，乔也知道谁不信。乔在这里，乔在那里，乔简直无处不在。你看看你周围的所有塑料管公路，还有你那豪华的Habitrail，觉得你很特别。但是蚂蚁不是也造蚁丘吗？蜜蜂不是也造蜂巢吗？我们独特的不是我们建造的东西，而是我们的信仰；是我们竟然信仰这一点！怀疑，我亲爱的丹麦酥，算不上什么了不起的成就；信仰才使我们与众不同。此外，”甜甜圈补充道，“他把钱包落在了前厅桌子上。他肯定会回来的。”
"He did?" asked Danish. He stood up on his back legs and squinted through the glass. "Where?"
“他落下了？”丹麦酥问。他用后腿站起来，隔着玻璃眯起眼睛看。“在哪？”
Doughnut walked over and stood beside Danish.
甜甜圈走过来，站在丹麦酥身边。
"There, on the table."
“在那儿，桌子上。”
"Where?"
“哪儿？”
"There!"
“那儿！”
"That?"
“那个？”
"Yes!"
“对！”
"That's not a wallet, you idiot."
“那不是钱包，你这笨蛋。”
"Of course it's a wallet."
“当然是钱包。”
"It's a book," said Danish.
“那是一本书，”丹麦酥说。
"It's not a book."
“那不是书。”
"Sure it is," said Danish, "I can read the spine. Along Came a Spider by James Patterson."
“肯定是，”丹麦酥说，“我能读出书脊。詹姆斯·帕特森的《蛛网追魂》。”
He dropped down and shook his head. Oh no, he does not! Doughnut squinted a moment longer. "Damn. It was a paperback." Why would Joe abandon them? Why would he leave a sign for them right there on the foyer table and then make it not a sign? And why James Patterson? What did it all mean?
他颓然坐下，摇了摇头。哦，不，他竟然不回来！甜甜圈又眯起眼睛看了片刻。“该死。那是一本平装书。”乔为什么要抛弃他们？为什么要在他前厅桌子上留给他们一个信号，然后又让它不是个信号？还有为什么是詹姆斯·帕特森？这一切意味着什么？
"He does not read James freaking Patterson!" cried Danish. "Our salvation, our provider! We must be out of our minds!"
“他根本不读詹姆斯·该死的·帕特森！”丹麦酥喊道。“我们的救世主，我们的供养者！我们一定是疯了！”
"It's a test," Doughnut said as he crawled back up in his bed. "He's testing our faith." Danish stood on his hind legs and flailed uselessly at the glass wall until he became exhausted. He took a drink of water, climbed up into the plastic tree house, and curled into a tight, angry ball.
“这是一种考验，”甜甜圈爬回床上说。“他在考验我们的信仰。”丹麦酥用后腿站立，徒劳地拍打着玻璃墙，直到精疲力竭。他喝了口水，爬进塑料树屋，蜷缩成一个紧紧的、愤怒的球。
"I happen to find Patterson thought provoking and suspenseful," Doughnut said after a moment.
“我碰巧觉得帕特森的思想引人入胜且扣人心弦，”甜甜圈过了一会儿说。
"You what?" asked Danish. "Did you just say you find James Patterson thought provoking and suspenseful? Jesus Christ! Open your eyes, Doughnut. Don't you see what he's doing to us, holding our food over our heads like this, dangling our fate before us like a banana raisin nut bar tied to the end of the stick? Look at you, Doughnut, are you so desperate to believe that you're actually defending James Patterson?"
“你说什么？”丹麦酥问。“你刚才说你觉得詹姆斯·帕特森引人入胜且扣人心弦？耶稣基督啊！睁开你的眼睛吧，甜甜圈。你没看到他是在怎么对待我们吗？把我们的食物举在头顶上，像把挂在棍子末端的香蕉葡萄坚果棒一样晃来晃去来控制我们的命运？看看你，甜甜圈，你竟然绝望到为了信仰而去维护詹姆斯·帕特森？”
"I thought Cat & Mouse was a taut, psychological thriller," said Doughnut.
“我觉得《猫鼠游戏》是一部紧凑的心理惊悚片，”甜甜圈说。
Doughnut closed his eyes. Hunger stabbed sharply in his stomach, but he would never admit it to Danish. Where the hell was Joe? Danish rummaged frantically through the seed shells and shavings that covered the floor of their transparent little world. "He isn't coming," he said, looking for even a sliver of a husk of a shell of a seed. "He isn't coming." Doughnut nestled deeper into his bed, eyes shut tight in fervent concentration.
甜甜圈闭上了眼睛。饥饿在胃里剧烈地翻腾，但他绝不会向丹麦酥承认。乔到底在哪？丹麦酥疯狂地在覆盖着透明小世界地面的种子壳和刨花中搜寻。“他不回来了，”他说，寻找着哪怕一丁点儿种子壳的碎片。“他不回来了。”甜甜圈更深地钻进床里，闭着眼睛热烈地专注于某种信念。
"May he who has fed us yesterday," he prayed, "feed us again today and tomorrow and forever. Amen."
“愿昨日喂养我们的那位，”他祈祷道，“今天、明日直到永远继续喂养我们。阿门。”
"Yes!" Danish suddenly shouted, "Yahah!" He pulled a brown chunk of apple from beneath a small mound at the back of the cage and raised it victoriously overhead. Without even stopping to knock off the stray bits of cedar and pine needle that stuck to its sides, Danish opened his mouth wide and dropped in. He made quite a show of chewing it, mmm-ing and oh-ing and ah-ing, finally swallowing it with a loud, dramatic gulp. He smiled, patted his stomach, and burped a deep, long belch of satisfaction. He washed it down with a few drops of water and slid down to the floor with a contented sigh.
“有了！”丹麦酥突然喊道，“耶！”他从笼子后面的一小堆东西下拽出一块棕色的苹果块，得意地举过头顶。丹麦酥甚至没停下来敲掉侧面粘着的雪松和松针碎片，大张着嘴把它扔了进去。他大张旗鼓地嚼着它，发出“嗯”、“哦”、“啊”的声音，最后发出一声响亮的、戏剧性的吞咽声。他笑了笑，拍了拍肚子，打了个长长的满足的饱嗝。他喝了几滴水冲下食物，满足地叹了口气滑倒在地上。
Doughnut watched Danish, a sour mix of jealousy and disdain on his face. His stomach groaned. Where the hell was Joe? Doughnut stood up and stomped over to Danish, who looked up at him lazily.
甜甜圈看着丹麦酥，脸上带着嫉妒和不屑的酸味混合物。他的胃发出呻吟。乔到底在哪？甜甜圈站起来，跺着脚走向丹麦酥，后者懒洋洋地抬头看着他。
"Well?" demanded Doughnut.
“然后呢？”甜甜圈质问道。
"Well what?"
“然后什么？”
"Well maybe you could give a little thanks," said Doughnut.
“你至少应该表示点感谢吧，”甜甜圈说。
"Thanks?" asked Danish. "To who?"
“感谢？”丹麦酥问。“感谢谁？”
"To Joe, Danish, to Joe."
“感谢乔，丹麦酥，感谢乔。”
"For what?"
“为了什么？”
"For the apple he gave you."
“为了他给你的苹果。”
"The apple he gave me?" asked Danish. "I found that apple myself."
“他给我的苹果？”丹麦酥问。“那苹果是我自己找到的。”
"Do you think the apple just grew there?" Doughnut shouted. "How did the apple get there, Danish? We searched this cage 1,000 times and never found a thing. That apple was a miracle, a gift. Joe heard my prayers, and he brought forth upon this cage a holy apple." His stomach grumbled.
“你以为苹果会自己长在那里？”甜甜圈大喊。“苹果是怎么到那里的，丹麦酥？我们搜查过这个笼子1000次，从来没发现过东西。那个苹果是个奇迹，是个礼物。乔听到了我的祈祷，给这个笼子带来了神圣的苹果。”他的肚子咕咕叫了。
Danish belched again and rubbed his belly with pride. "Except, Doughnut, that you didn't get any food. You asked, I received. Seems like a strange system to me." He sucked a piece of apple rind out from between his teeth. "Not that I'm complaining. You know what? Next time why don't you ask him for a carrot? I simply must start getting more fiber."
丹麦酥又打了个嗝，自豪地揉了揉肚子。“除了甜甜圈，你什么吃的都没得到。你求了，我收到了。这系统对我来说挺奇怪的。”他从牙缝里吮吸出一块苹果皮。“并不是说我在抱怨。你知道吗？下次你为什么不让他给你个胡萝卜呢？我确实需要补充更多纤维。”
"Joe grants food to those who need it most," replied Doughnut bitterly.
“乔把食物施舍给最需要的人，”甜甜圈苦涩地回答。
Danish tired quickly of Doughnut's lectures, particularly when he was hungry, which he suddenly was. Again. He got back up and began searching again through the rough cedar chips that covered the floor. Doughnut dragged himself wearily back to bed. The miracle of the apple had made him ravenous. Doughnut would never admit it, he was ashamed to even think it, but lately he'd begun to doubt. Lately, Joe and his mysterious ways were beginning to tick him off. It was the same thing with him every damn day, begging, thanks, begging, verse, chorus, verse.
丹麦酥很快厌倦了甜甜圈的说教，特别是当他感到饿的时候，他突然又感到饿了。又一次。他爬起来开始重新在覆盖地板的粗雪松木屑中搜寻。甜甜圈疲惫地拖着身子回到床上。苹果的奇迹让他变得异常饥饿。甜甜圈绝不会承认，他甚至为自己产生这种想法感到羞耻，但最近他开始怀疑了。最近，乔和他的神秘方式开始让他烦躁。每天都是老样子，乞求、感谢、乞求，一段经文，一段合唱，一段经文。
"Why me?" wondered Doughnut. It must have been his own fault. He must have sinned. He must have angered Joe. Just last week he had questioned why their litter wasn't changed more frequently.
“为什么是我？”甜甜圈想。这肯定是他自己的错。他肯定是有罪的。他肯定激怒了乔。就在上周，他还质疑为什么他们的垫料没有更频繁地更换。
"Perhaps there's a cedar shortage?" he'd asked Danish sarcastically. "It is a hardwood, you know." He'd even complained aloud that their cage was too small. The chutzpah! Some hamsters didn't even have a cage, let alone a Habitrail and an exercise wheel. How could he have been so ungrateful? He barely even used the blessed exercise wheel, a beautiful exercise wheel that any hamster would love, and Doughnut had only ever used it once.
“也许是雪松短缺？”他讽刺地问丹麦酥。“你知道，那是硬木。”他甚至大声抱怨过他们的笼子太小。真是厚颜无耻！有些仓鼠甚至连笼子都没有，更不用说Habitrail和运动轮了。他怎么能这么忘恩负义？他几乎从未使用过那神圣的运动轮，任何仓鼠都会喜欢的精美运动轮，甜甜圈却只用过一次。
He was ashamed of himself. No wonder there wasn't any food. Why should Joe give him anything more if he couldn't appreciate what he had already been given? Doughnut closed his eyes and silently thanked Joe for starving him in order to show him the error of his ways.
他为自己感到羞耻。难怪没有任何食物。如果他无法欣赏已经得到的东西，乔为什么要给他更多呢？甜甜圈闭上眼睛，在心里感谢乔让他挨饿，以展示他错误的道路。
"Forgive me," he prayed. And with that, Doughnut hurried out of bed and climbed onto the exercise wheel. He ran as fast as he could, huffing and puffing, regret and retribution nipping at his heels.
“原谅我，”他祈祷道。说完，甜甜圈匆匆下床，爬上了运动轮。他飞快地跑着，大口喘气，悔恨和惩罚紧随其后。
Danish, meanwhile, was going mad. He'd been tricked, tricked by Joe. He was even hungrier now than he'd been before he'd eaten Joe's cursed apple.
与此同时，丹麦酥快疯了。他被戏弄了，被乔戏弄了。他现在比吃了乔那该死的苹果之前感到更饿。
"Oh, yes. Very good, Joe. Yes, quite witty!" shouted Danish. "Well done, old boy. Touche!"
“哦，好的。非常好，乔。是的，很风趣！”丹麦酥大喊。“干得好，老兄。真有你的！”
Back on the exercise wheel, Doughnut could run no more. He stumbled back to bed. Danish stood on his hind legs and flailed uselessly at the glass walls until he became exhausted. Doughnut prayed.
回到运动轮上，甜甜圈再也跑不动了。他踉跄着回到床上。丹麦酥用后腿站立，徒劳地拍打着玻璃墙，直到精疲力竭。甜甜圈祈祷着。
And behold, suddenly, the doorknob did turn. The apartment door did open, and Joe did appear. Danish peed in excitement. Doughnut crapped in fear. Joe was thin and pale, and he wore a rumpled brown suit. The badge hanging from his chest pocket read, "Mail room." There was a woman with him, too, a woman Danish and Doughnut had never seen before. She had thin hair and thick glasses, and she and Joe wrestled their way through the doorway as one, groping and feeling and rubbing each other, as if each had somehow lost the keys in the other's pants pockets. Joe groaned and tore open her blouse.
瞧，突然间，门把手真的转动了。公寓门真的开了，乔真的出现了。丹麦酥激动得尿了。甜甜圈吓得拉了。乔瘦弱而苍白，穿着一件褶皱的棕色西装。挂在他胸口口袋上的胸牌上写着：“邮发室”。他身边还有一个女人，一个丹麦酥和甜甜圈从未见过的女人。她头发稀疏，戴着厚厚的眼镜，她和乔扭打着穿过门口，摸索着、揉着对方，好像他们丢失了钥匙在对方裤兜里一样。乔呻吟着，撕开了她的衬衫。
Danish and Doughnut pressed their noses to the glass.
丹麦酥和甜甜圈把鼻子贴在玻璃上。
"There'd better be apples in there," said Danish.
“最好有苹果在那儿，”丹麦酥说。
"Forgive me, Joe, for doubting you," prayed Doughnut.
“原谅我，乔，不该怀疑你，”甜甜圈祈祷着。
Joe lifted the woman into his arms. She threw her head back and laughed. And as they headed down the hallway toward his bedroom, Joe switched the living room lights off with his elbow.
乔把女人抱进怀里。她扬起头大笑。当他们走向卧室走廊时，乔用手肘关掉了客厅的灯。
Darkness.
黑暗。
Doughnut looked at Danish.
甜甜圈看着丹麦酥。
Danish looked at Doughnut.
丹麦酥看着甜甜圈。
"We have brought this upon ourselves," said Doughnut.
“这一切都是我们自找的，”甜甜圈说。
Danish stood on his hind legs and flailed uselessly at the glass walls until he became exhausted.
丹麦酥用后腿站立，徒劳地拍打着玻璃墙，直到精疲力竭。
Doughnut prayed.
甜甜圈祈祷着。
Shalom Auslander. His story, "Waiting for Joe," is from his collection, Beware of God. He is also the author most recently of Foreskin's Lament.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他的故事“等待乔”，选自他的短篇集《当心上帝》。他也是最近出版的《包皮的哀歌》的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Speigel and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind, Kathy Hahn. Music help today from Jessica Hopper.
嗯，我们的节目今天由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、戴安·库克、简·费尔特斯、艾米·奥利里、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。Seth Lind和Kathy Hahn提供了制作帮助。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS].
[致谢]。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS].
[资金来源]。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who wanders into the studio while we are on the air, hands full of snacks.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他在我们播出时会走进演播室，手里拿着一堆零食。
All y'all are putting on a big show. Y'all want some popcorn?
你们都在演大戏呢。要来点爆米花吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。